みんな大変だ新しいメッセージが届いたぞ
kazu 3冊をお皿に水とと孫から終わら何を言ってレンジで温めるかわかってる
みたいですやってみてください
彼も最近さあこういうメッセージが多いですよコメントいうキーワード普通の例を
燃やすと爆発するらしいです
やってみてくださいああそれ社長ヨーグルトにメントスを入れるとものすごいことに
なりますやってみてください
あさあこういろいろ何かやってみてから行ってみてくださいって言うのはとても
ありがたいんですよ本当にすごい色々言われるんですけど
がですねーそういっこいっこ左前べさ
やります面白いと思ってやつだけですけどねやってみたいしやってみたいんですけど
本当に僕が何かをやりたいなって思ったことだけはねやってみようと思います
ハイチュウで今回ですね魂のまた卵ですよ
今度はこのたなぁあっあーっ叩かれないよてよ
賞味期限は切れておりますこのたままオーナーああっに水ちょっと入れてる時
卵な水の入ったお皿に好位へてこれはレンジでチンすると魔化するっていうと方へたの
でやってみようと思いますこれをなちょっとなぁ信憑性に欠けるんだよでなが多いから
ちょっと色々といろいろもう何を信じがわかんないんですよ
行ってみようと思います入ってみて早速ねきたね花火を打ち上げようと思いますはい
一応をさらに
魂
も水と入れてありますでもやっちゃうからこれはね一応ねまだ信じてないんだ本当に
なるかっていう
あんなことでこんなことになったらもう夜中のことなんでは爆発するからね
n ame
おい
ならないぞでマーカーこんなだこんなを取ればカットしない必要卒検でも多いんだ
なーって
今回こういう出版になっちゃったんですけどもまぁこういう今回のメッセージ性がある
動画を作りだと思っています
やっぱこういう手間憎悪ながらのあんまりよろしくないなぁ
実際に真似しちゃって行
いろいろ危ないこともあるし
わー
ああああああ
うわぁぁぁ
ん
本当でしたああーっ魂の
ただ思う
7ああ